[Music]
welcome to this latest dw business
special i'm christy platson in berlin
today we're looking at the euro's weak
performance against the dollar for the
first time in 20 years one euro is now
worth just one dollar that's also known
as parity which means the exchange rate
is one to one
now the euro has been under pressure for
some time now since the beginning of the
year it has lost 13 u.s cents in value
the war in ukraine and dependence on
russian gas are hitting the currency as
is monetary policy now euro dollar
parity means eurozone exports to the u.s
are cheaper a possible silver lining for
export-oriented countries like germany
but u.s goods are also more expensive
for europeans to import for businesses
this means passing those costs onto
customers who are already struggling to
keep up with high consumer prices
well joining me at my small desk to talk
about this is cassandra sundt from the
business desk thank you for being with
us we also have karsten brzezki on the
line he's chief economist at ing germany
hi carson thank you both for joining me
i want to get to carson in a moment but
first to start with cassandra now
cassandra i know that you have ties to
the states uh how is this currency
situation affecting you this is
obviously a really small story but for
me personally i went to university in
the u.s and so i have student loans that
are due in american dollars and i've
noticed that that number has started to
tick down how many uh dollars i can buy
for my euros and i actually went back
and looked what exactly is going on and
in june 2020 i could get about 221 for
200 euros and now it's 200 for 200 and
of course i don't expect any uh violin
sad violin music to play for me
necessarily i will be okay with uh hit
losing those ten dollars per month uh i
like a lot of europeans are much more
concerned about rising food prices and
this looming energy crisis we have
coming okay right but it's a great
example that uh euros are getting weaker
if you're if you're needing to pay for
things in dollars so uh yeah now carson
turning to you for a bit of a european
perspective what about yourself or
people that you know are you i don't
know doubting about taking that u.s road
trip this summer what can you tell us
well i'm i'm too old to still have to
pay back my my u.s student loan but um
obviously it's extremely expensive
enough for tourists going to the us and
on the other hand everything like you
said at the beginning everything that we
import not only from the us but also
everything that we import which is
simply invoiced in u.s dollars will
become even more expensive and uh you
talked about the energy crisis now in
which currency is oil gas and all other
commodities invoiced in u.s dollars so
this energy commodity bill for uh for
europeans will increase even further
right great point karsten i mean what
we're hearing from both of you is that a
weak euro is a major headache for
europeans um but as you just um talking
about tourism americans or anyone with
us dollars their cash is going to go
farther now in europe than it has in a
while so any of those lucky souls who
have managed to brave pandemic
restrictions air travel chaos and are
still able to make eurotrip 2022 they're
ready to splash out let's take a look
it's great the parody makes it easy for
us and
a lot our money goes a lot further now
it's cheaper to come here and
buy stuff so it's better to come here i
guess i'm very excited that our american
dollar is so strong just when i'm coming
to
europe
it definitely encourages us to spend
it's like it's on sale here so
i think the dollar and euro being at
together at the same amount is great for
americans our dollar is buying us more
it seemed like the buying power didn't
really affect me too much we were
actually able to purchase everything in
advance
all right i want to go to carson on this
now so we just heard a few different uh
opinions on the situation
euro is cheap we also heard though from
cassandra that eurozone inflation at a
record high right now consumer prices
were up 8.6 uh percent in june compared
to a year ago karsten are dollar holders
really getting such a good deal right
now um here in
europe well inflation in europe is still
somewhat lower than in the u.s so you
could argue with this this weak euro us
dollar holders will get a better bargain
in a year of these days well if you then
deduct the cost for traveling to europe
but
the other thing is
what we normally learn from textbooks is
that european exporters benefit from a
weak currency so german car makers for
example exporting their cars to the us
or other european stuff
which is true in theory but i think
currently given that there are so many
constraints in supply chains in
deliveries
in additional costs for producers i
really think that the the disadvantages
of a weak currency that is higher
inflation higher imported inflation
clearly outweighs any benefits that we
had in the past from a weaker currency
namely that it was supporting
exports all right this is the exact next
point i want to talk about with
cassandra we just heard it from carsten
you know that we're seeing these higher
costs it's going to cost more for
european businesses to import things
that are priced in dollars crucially a
lot of very important commodities like
oil for example are priced in dollars
the the importers are probably going to
have to pass these costs on to consumers
we know prices are already going up are
they going to go up even further now
well unfortunately there's really no
sign that things are about to get
cheaper right since the beginning of the
year we've seen inflation consistently
above five percent and it's been
trending upwards uh the current
inflation rate like we discussed is at
eight point six percent so let's say for
example in this imaginary world next
month inflation rate was cut in half
that puts us at 4.3 percent that would
be nice but that's still an inflation
rate of 4.3 percent which is double what
the ecb the european central bank's goal
is and so even if
you know viewers are hearing things like
the inflation rate is slowing
unfortunately that just means things are
getting more expensive at a slower rate
so all in all it's really not a great
outlook for consumers at the moment okay
interesting carson i'm curious if you
have any thoughts about what cassandra
said or about uh yeah the prospect of
prices going up in general
no that was very well explained so the
student loan clearly pays off um so i
think this this is really the issue here
so inflation is going to stay high even
if the headline inflation numbers were
to come down which i don't expect
actually in the shorter run um because i
think that producers producers of goods
but also producers of services will
still try to to put some price markups
into the economy let's think of the
hospitality services think of other
services leisure um culture so all these
sectors that were hit the most by the
pandemic by the lockdowns they will try
to charge price markups so thereby in no
way will we see things actually getting
cheaper again we will see inflation
coming down but as cassandra nicely
explained inflation coming down still
means that stuff goods services are
getting more expensive only at a slower
pace
okay well not exactly what i want to
hear carson but i believe you so i want
to talk about how this is going to
develop some more in a minute but first
let's take a look back at how we got
here in the first place this parity
situation has been quite a long time in
the making in fact i mean the last time
the dollar and the euro were at par was
in december 2002 that's right before the
euro turned three since then the euro
has held its own quite well against the
dollar in december 2007 10 euros could
buy you 14 and change the two currencies
reached their highest difference during
the financial crunch of 2008 at one
point 10 euros could buy you almost 16
now they stand one to one 10 euros gets
you just around 10
so cassandra to you again shortly after
the euro was introduced currency dealers
had nicknamed it the uh toilet currency
because of how quickly it was going down
against the greenback how did the euro
make such a comeback uh after that right
the idea was it was gonna keep going
down and down and down uh that nickname
uh i think it's really uh the euro has
proven that nickname wrong in my opinion
this was a currency at the time that was
part of a new experiment the shared
currency across many countries and uh
since that time where it first reached
parity in 2002
we saw it bounce back just a few years
later six years later in fact to 16
euros to 10 dollars some research that i
was doing at the time when they were
talking about parity at the moment to
use a german word there was a little bit
of schadenfreude i think coming from
some of these writers in english exactly
um and since then you know there was
there's been a lot that's changed so
when we reached parity there was
economic decline in europe while the u.s
was rising i looked at some statistics
at the time the u.s was growing seven
times faster than europe in this kind of
moment around 2002
and that was led by a big decline in
europe's biggest economy which at the
time and still is germany uh germany was
uh still dealing with the ramifications
of reunification kind of investing in uh
these 16 million people that had
rejoined germany at the time so there
was a little bit of a slowdown in the
german economy but in this moment seven
years before the financial crisis in
that seven years leading up to the
financial crisis i should say german
exports rose 76
and that was a big part of the story of
how europe kind of bounced back and
there are a lot of factors at play here
but that one really stuck out at me
because like we kind of were already
discussing this could be a silver lining
this could be a moment for exporters to
to get a little bit of a boost and that
in turn chicken and egg what will we see
first but that could be a moment uh for
the euro to start to turn around
okay yeah interesting point interesting
point um now hopping back to july 2022
where we are now carson going to you i
mean in some ways the story of the weak
euro is more of an energy story than it
is a currency story we know that the dip
came after gas flows through russia's
nordstrom one pipeline were shut off for
maintenance that's of course the main
pipeline providing gas to germany can
you talk to me how are energy and
currency related in this situation
well here i think energy and currency
are related as such that that currency
traders our french market expect the the
energy crisis higher energy prices to
really dent economic growth so we are
looking into some kind of recession in
the european economy in fall and in
winter how mild how severe it will be
clearly depends on whether or not we
will get a full stop of russian gas
going to germany and other european
countries but this is clearly the so it
is the energy story and the impact that
the energy story has on economic
development because when you look at you
mentioned we we were at 122 last last
summer
and since then what has happened since
then we've seen that there is monetary
policy differences so the u.s central
bank the federal is starting to hike
interest rates but then we have the war
and since the war started
we have uncertainty in europe everyone
knows that europe is the weakest spot
currently in the global economy
suffering from higher energy and
commodity prices suffering from from
uncertainty and these factors have
really made that the people and traders
investors have withdrawn their
investments from europe and this means
we're going to have this falling in
currency
okay so what i'm hearing now from carson
from cassandra here is that this energy
crisis also other factors are weighing
majorly on the economy here and
consequently also on its currency now um
here in germany we know that the price
of oil and gas have continued to drive
up consumer prices in june this has been
a major pain point for the european
central bank whose whole mandate of
course is price stability
now obviously they can't control the war
in ukraine disrupting energy markets but
that doesn't really get them off the
hook doesn't cassandra
so i want to talk to you about that in a
second
also hear from carson but first let's
hear what ecb president christine
lagarde had to say
given its energy dependence the euro
area is experiencing these shocks
acutely
the current level of food and industrial
goods inflation have not been seen seen
since the mid 80s
and the increase in the relative price
of energy in recent months
is much higher
than the individual spikes that occurred
in the 70s
okay well cassandra we just heard from
the president of the ecb now we just
spoke with carson about how this
currency story is also an energy story
but it's also a story about interest
rates we know that the u.s federal
reserve has been more aggressive about
raising interest rates than the ecb has
been and this is uh increasing
confidence in the u.s economy and
consequently in the in the u.s dollar as
well now with this development with
parity uh you know arriving this week
euro dollar um the ecb is meeting uh for
their next monthly meeting next week
what do you think they'll be talking
about what could come out of that i
think they're clearly under pressure
last month there was an easy beating as
well ecb meeting as well and there was
the signal that they're now authorized
to maybe do something about interest
rates and now next thursday
we're going to be seeing this meeting
finally happening i was looking back i
was curious because you know we've read
a little bit about what the fed has done
in terms of interest rates i was like
what what was the interest rates over
the past few years and it's
a decade basically a flat line over the
last six years but they haven't gone up
for a decade it's like a slight decline
bunny hill bunny hill flat right so
they're going to be under a ton of
pressure here and as i was starting to
get rid into the story and get an
understanding of what we're going to be
looking for i read this bloomberg survey
of 28 economists and 22 of them actually
think that even if the ecb acts they've
acted too late because as we've seen
since the beginning of the year the fed
has been much more aggressive so
the ecb generally more conservative i
think the pressure is going to be on on
thursday especially after this parity
news this week for them to take some
concrete action to reassure their member
states well as i said in our episode
about rising interest rates the ecb does
somehow have my sympathies they've got a
lot of factors to to keep control right
now carson do you have any thoughts on
this anything to add to what cassandra
said about the ecb interest rates
anything
definitely i think the dilemma or the
problem for the ecb is nothing they can
do will produce more energy and will
make it cheaper or will make the war
stop or will produce more microchips at
the same time they know if they start
hiking interest rates to sharpen too
aggressively they would cool down the
demand side of the economy so they would
actually do even more harm to the
economy that's also not in the interest
of the ecb so it's really a balancing
act they have reacted too late uh when
you look at other central banks we
currently talk about rate heights by 75
basis points by 100 basis points while
the ecb is looking at maybe or not maybe
doing 25 basis points next week we'll
you know we're doing more stop the fall
of the euro for a couple of hours maybe
for a couple of days
but what the ecu would have to do if it
wanted to stop really the fall of the
euro they would have to say yes we're
going to hike aggressively more
aggressively than financial markets are
currently thinking and we're going to
deliver even more rate hikes and the
latter is something they cannot tell
financial market because they know they
are looking into a looming recession we
have a government crisis in italy we
might have another debt crisis in the
eurozone so the ecb really needs to
treat extremely carefully 25 basis
points next week another rate hike in
september and that might probably be
already it
all right well now carson to close us
out in our talk here you wrote recently
that quote europe's recovery is
cancelled uh now since then nordstrom
one has been shut off the euro dropped
below the dollar a little bit so at this
parity uh we're talking about now what
is your crystal ball showing you now for
the next few months ahead as we get into
autumn winter who is cancelled next
well it's not going to be cancelled next
uh we're gonna we're gonna see a
recession uh and an economist defines
the recession as two consecutive
quarters with economic contraction this
is what we're looking at right now we
have these high inflation numbers which
are going to dent private consumption
which are an increasing burden on profit
margins from corporates so this alone
is already pushing down the eurozone
economy into a mild recession if we were
to see this additional energy supply
disruptions read a stop of russian
energy floating to uh to europe we would
not only talk about a mild winter
recession or we talked about a severe
recession in the eurozone so it's not
only recovery cancel it is recovery
cancelled welcome recession
all right carson thank you so much we're
gonna have to leave it there it's been a
nice chat with both of you but obviously
a very sobering takeaway that we've
ended with here that's all we have for
you this week from our small desk we'll
be back with another dw business special
uh next for you next week i want to
thank again carson brzezki from ing
germany for joining us also my colleague
cassandra sun from the dw business desk
from us and the whole from the whole
team here in berlin thank you so much
for watching the show we'll see you next
week
you